public sénat en partenariat avec l' afp
les échos radio classique présente
jean christophe cambadélis le premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste est
l'invité cette semaine de l'épreuve de
vérité bonsoir bonsoir et merci d'être
avec nous donc pour ce rendez-vous de
public sénat avec nous l'avons dit radio
classique et les échos et l' agence
france presse et au cours de cette
émission vous répondrez à trois grandes
questions jean francis pécresse vous
demandera d'abord dans un instant si
françois hollande pourra se représenter
puisque les sondages on le voit sont
toujours très mauvais ils s'accumulent
deuxième question le cil malandain vous
interrogera ensuite sur la gauche et l
irréconciliable c'est l'image qui ne
donne plus que jamais en ce moment enfin
mickaël szames s vous demandera si on ne
se dirige pas tout droit vers un nouveau
21 avril un duel droite extrême droite
en 2017 mais d'abord jean christophe
cambadélis une question d'actualité
questions d'actualité dès que vous
devenez français vos ancêtres son goût
loi a lancé hier soir nicolas sarkozy en
meeting à val-d oise est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec cette idée
ça fait un peu l'histoire pour les nuls
c'est vrai que sarkozy et cambadélis
s'est totalement gaulois je crois que la
france marche ou mélanges et elle marche
bien parce que vous êtes choqués par
cette formule c'est du sarkozy n'en
texte en de l'à peu près de la
provocation
essayez de faire le buzz autour de lui
on a retrouvé le sarkozy d'avant il nous
fait une petite rechute l'a1 mais que
comme vous il à eelv est un français de
sang mêlé il le revendique et on est
d'accord et lui donc dit mes ancêtres ce
sont vos lois point vous dit vous n'êtes
pas la même chose mais ils sont sept
sont mes ancêtres et il l'était pas
gaulois puisqu'ils n'étaient pas
français
et donc il y a eu un processus
d'intégration dans la société française
tout en gardant un certain nombre
d'éléments culturels je bois sûrement
plus dorée de sina que le lait france le
français moyen et je mange sûrement
beaucoup plus grec que l'ensemble de mes
compatriotes mais ça ne fait pas pour
moi de moi quelqu'un qui n'est pas
assimilé pour reprendre la formule de
nicolas sarkozy alors justement il met
en avant cette notion d'assimilation est
ce qu'il ne faut pas entendre sa sortie
en fait comme un avertissement face au
danger
aujourd'hui du multiculturalisme et face
notamment à la poussée du
fondamentalisme musulman dans notre pays
il propose un pacte de d'assimilation
sous-entendu que il y à des français
qu'ils ne seraient pas de souche
c'est exactement ce que dit le front
national il n'y a pas de divergence et
même ça le pack d'assimilation jean
marie le pen n'a jamais osé le dire dans
aucun de ses meetings et dans aucune de
ces déclarations tant qu on voit
jusqu'où on est arrivé nicolas sarkozy
pour essayer de faire venir à lui
l'électorat frontiste jeudi que tout
ceci est un danger pour la france parce
que cela met l amène à jeter les
français les uns contre les autres
est ce que vous êtes français vous
n'êtes pas français votre culture n'est
pas française s'est pas de ça qu'il faut
c'est la cohésion nationale et ensemble
affronter les problèmes donc vous nous
dites qu'en fait le front national est
débordé sur son extrême droite par
nicolas sarkozy avec cette phrase sur
nos ancêtres les gaulois pas sur cette
phrase sur les ancêtres les oies sur son
pacte d'assimilation mais je crois oui
que le cours actuel de nicolas sarkozy
qui est de construire un programme
commun entre une droite extrême et une
extrême droite et il est en train qui
arrivait d'ailleurs tout le monde à
droite s'aligne sur lui personne ne peut
résister dans ce domaine mais vous avez
vu les déclarations depuis ce matin jean
christophe cambadélis il y a beaucoup de
distance prise par tous les autres
candidats à la primaire ont pensé les
sens terminent en jupes et je pense à
grenoble sur la formule les gaulois elle
est tellement caricaturale que les
critiques dans son camp il y critiquait
sur cette formule et pour le reste
pour le reste sur tous les sujets tout
le monde s'aligne sur nicolas sarkozy
juppé a sur ce terrain là une un
alignement complet il l'a dit dans
valeurs actuelles
ce week-end il a indiqué que dans les
mesures du regroupement familial ou le
reste il l'avait dit avant
nicolas sarkozy donc on ne peut pas dire
non je n'entend aucune nouvelle quand
vous dites que tout le monde wazi et
juppé c'est les frères siamois d'une
même politique
l'épreuve de vérité avait crédit
classique et les échos bonsoir en
français bonsoir michel bonsoir jean
christophe cambadélis
alors votre question en premier
secrétaire du ps lorsque vous voyez les
cotes de popularité les courbes
d'intentions de vote est ce que vous
pensez vraiment que françois hollande
sera en capacité de se présenter à la
présidence de la république
tout dépend de lui c'est pas les
sondages qui vont décider c'est lui qui
décidera s'il est candidat ou pas et
s'il décide d'être candidat même s'il ya
des mauvais sondages
il sera candidat c'est très mauvais
sondages très mauvais sondages mais il y
à des sondages dans une période où dans
un moment où personne ne connaît les
candidats personne ne connaît le
programme est simplement 30% des
français s'intéressent à la
présidentielle alors je sais que pour
les médias
c'est embêtant mais c'est la réalité
donc il faudrait parler du fait que
aujourd'hui les français ne sont pas
dans la présidentielle on n'est pas
candidat que par envie par choix on est
candidat parce qu'on sent dans l'opinion
une aspiration une véritable envie est
ce que vous sentez chez les français une
envie de françois hollande
quand les braves candidats de renan
tirades et de françois on n'est pas
candidat pour une envie chez les
français on l'a su site on est candidat
parce qu'on a un dessin pour la france
ça c'est là définitivement ce projet dès
la définition que du général de gaulle
qui est l un des ces instituts ciel
était un dialogue entre un homme et
un destin un dessein pour son peuple
le projet il vous le dira s'il est
candidat il va le développer je le
suppose
dans un entretien récent au quotidien le
monde et à la revue débat françois
hollande dit être porteur d'une france
fraternelle qu'est ce que ça veut dire
être porteur d'une france fraternelle et
qui peut le croire quand la france sort
de mouvements aussi rude que les
mouvements contre la manif pour tous où
les manifestations contre la loi travail
mais on peut manifester est fraternelle
ce n'est pas contradictoire
la fraternité la fraternité laïque telle
que nous la concevons c'est la
possibilité du vivre ensemble c'est une
autre manière de poser le vivre ensemble
nous estimons dieu il avait parié sur
une société apaisée
car elle n'est pas apaisé parce qu'elle
a été percuté par le terroriste pas
parce qu'il n'a pas pu l'apaiser
comprenons nous nous avons une
divergence majeure majeur qui fait tout
un projet un projet de société avec la
droite et l'extrême droite aujourd'hui
sur ce que doit être la france nous nous
voulons une france fraternelle
nous voulons pas de césure au milieu de
la france nous ne désignons pas une
partie de la population comme étant les
fauteurs de trouble ou dix ans
reprendre un certain nombre de formules
que la france a un programme un problème
avec eux ça c'était effectivement
c'était effectivement le discours de la
salle wagram ça n'a eu aucun effet dans
l'opinion publique quand on lit encore
une fois les sondages de popularité et
les sondages d'intentions de vote est à
dire que geste après geste il ne se
passe pour françois hollande rien comme
si les français l'avaient ap en quelque
sorte est ce que ça ne vous inquiète pas
quand même je ne le pense pas ces
discours infuse
ils sont des éléments de référence nous
les diffusons nous faisons en sorte
qu'il soit entendu réparé régler la jean
christophe cambadélis aveugle et moi
jamais je suis assez irréaliste assez
clair mais non mais il réaliste c'est
quand on n'est pas d'accord avec vous
non je serai réaliste par rapport à
l'analyse que je me fais de la situation
politique la droite via son référence
aux primaires ne réglera pas son
problème stratégique y aura deux
candidats de droite
vers et l'extrême droite est à un niveau
que l'on n'a jamais vu en france il ya
beaucoup de choses qui vont se passer
jusqu'à l'élection présidentielle
et je pense que c'est beaucoup plus
ouvert qu'on veut bien le dire
est ce que les conseillers des cabinets
ministériels n'ont pas eu déjà voté en
quelque sorte puisqu'il apparemment ils
fuient les cabinets 10% des effectifs
sont déjà partis et ne sont pas
remplacés
est-ce que ça n'est pas un signe très
inquiétant du bourg sens et pas 10 %
vont pas excessif
mais vous savez c'est tellement magique
ça c'est le titre du monde qui ont fait
que sa campagne
non c'est pas hémorragie il y avait
quasiment la même chose à la fin de
sarkozy bon alors il prévoyait aussi la
défaite de ce dernier peut-être
non je crois que c'est normal qu'un
sauve qui peut softeam a dit compris à
l'elysée pour cent sauf qu'ils peuvent
non vous savez un sauve qui peut c'est
90% ce qui n'est pas le cas mais ce
n'est pas anormal vu le fait que l' on
le dit du matin jeu ce soir
les jeux sont faits c'est le bal à peine
d'aller voter la droite est qualifiée
est ce que le président
on est donc monté dans cette situation
aujourd'hui on nous dit marine le pen
pas de problème elle est au 2e tour la
droite et le et au deuxième tour il ne
reste plus qu'à la gauche d'essayer de
soutenir le candidat républicain moi je
vous dis ça ne se passera pas comme ça
parce que les français vont voter sur
quel bilan sur un bilan contrasté qui
pourra être présenté aux français et ce
bilan
moi je veux le confronter aux projets de
la droite sur tous les sujets un bilan
contrasté c'est d'ailleurs ainsi que l'a
constaté ça veut dire que et bien réussi
sur du mauvais pas du mauvais on n'a pas
réussi sur tout mais on a réussi à
redresser la france et c'est un élément
je crois extrêmement positif mais nous
sommes là dans l'absolu c'est à dire
pour terminer les sondages qui
aujourd'hui qui est contre le
gouvernement au nom les choses très
simplement
l'extrême droite 30% les républicains 30
à 35% like l'extrême gauche 10 à 12% et
une partie de la gauche des frondeurs
qui sont je sais pas combien disons si
on prend les derniers sondages pour
montreux beau entre 5 et 7%
comment voulez vous dans ces conditions
là
que nous soyons majoritaire nous le
sommes pas donc le jour où il y aura
trois ou quatre candidats ils ont leur
programme ils auront ce qu'ils ont fait
et il dit pourront qu on pourra comparer
les français comparent on dans
l'éducation nationale ce que nous avons
fait et ce qu'on nous propose de faire
ils compareront sur la question du tiers
payant ce que nous avons fait et ce que
la droite veut défaire et ainsi de suite
à mon avis ça changera la vision des
français
tout le monde le sais françois hollande
avait lié sa candidature à une inversion
de la courbe du chômage
donc depuis le début de l'année 2016 le
chômage en france baisse de 75 mille
personnes 17 64 personnes n'en reste pas
moins que depuis le mois de mai 2012
on a un solde positif de 5 185 mille
chômeurs en plus que nous avons un taux
de chômage de 9 et demi pour cent que en
ce moment même
l'allemagne est à moins de six que le
royaume uni est à 5 que la suisse est à
3 est ce que ce bilan la peut lui
permettre de se représenter devant les
français de manière sérieuse tout à fait
parce qu'il a engagé un processus de
baisse du chômage qui les liera teach
vous le concède mais qui est une
tendance et qui a été très fortement
annoncé chez les chez les plus jeunes
même si dans d'autres catégories
nous sommes à rester à des niveaux qui
ne sont pas acceptables
on peut se comparer avec nos partenaires
vous savez très bien que en allemagne ou
en angleterre le le travail partiel le
travail pour un euro ou 2 euros ou 10
euros est un travail qui est extrêmement
vous pourrez répandu créé d'en avoir
inversé la courbe du chômage
menant nous avons nous pouvons prétendre
nous pouvons prétendre avoir réussi à
remettre la france sur les rails du
point de vue de la lutte contre le
chômage dont de la croissance donc de la
création d'emplois parce qu'on dit
jamais jamais que aujourd'hui le pari du
chef de l'état ait perdu dans le paris
du chu du chef de l'état n'est pas
totalement gagné gagné mais il est bien
engagé
quand donc que l'inversion elle reste
encore à faire mais l'inversion total
elle reste à faire évidemment mais vous
voyez bien comment nous sommes engagés
et vous savez je ne pense pas que les
français seront
à ce point critique tel que le sont les
journalistes est telle que le sont les
sondeurs parce que ils se souviendront
de la situation dans laquelle la droite
nous a laissé le pays et ils verront
qu'on a fait les efforts sur nous mêmes
au niveau de l'état qu'on a engagé le
pays dans une bonne vos questions sur le
taux des prélèvements obligatoires c'est
à dire le montant total des impôts des
taxes des charges était acquis reste à
44 et demi pour cent c'est un niveau
pratiquement record il n'a pratiquement
pas baissé il a même augmenté un peu
depuis le début du quinquennat
2 du quinquennat de françois hollande ça
veut dire que le choc fiscal et a
toujours mais nous sommes en train de
rendre aux français ça se voit par ce
que l'on leur a emprunté sar n'a pas
dans les pois pourquoi on l'a fait c'est
parce que nous on a décidé qu'il fallait
augmenter les impôts
par idéologie ou par construction non
c'est parce que nous avions des déficits
colossaux laissé par la droite et qu'on
n'allait pas laisser le pays à la
banqueroute fillon avait dit je suis
confronté un pays qui n'a plus d'argent
en caisse
nous en avons remis l'épreuve de vérité
avec life fille
bonsoir lucile montfort mont saint
michel manche thouarcé cambadélis votre
question mon premier secrétaire du parti
socialiste alors manel valls l'avait
prédit il y a quelques mois nous sommes
maintenant à sept mois de la
présidentielle la gauche et l
irréconciliable mois ces débats m'amuse
un peu parce que pour moi la gauche et
eric conciliables depuis 1920 partir du
moment où il ya eu la scission entre les
sociaux démocrates socialistes et les
communistes
elle est irréconciliable la question qui
est posée c'est qu'est ce que est ce qu
elle peut ou pas s'unir à des moments
donnés récolte l'histoire l'histoire a
montré que mémé il quand nous étions
unis nous étions tout autant il réponse
fiable
nous avions des dvd des divergences
majeures on n'a jamais vu un parti
unique de l'ensemble de la gauche je lé
souhaitait un moment donné j'ai constaté
que ce n'était pas possible
les communistes resteront communistes
les écologistes restaurant et
écologistes et les socialistes resteront
socialiste ça me paraît normal ils ont
une culture de gouvernement que n'ont
pas les autres c'est ce qui fait les
difficultés du rassemblement mais quand
il s'agit de s'unir regardez dans les
collectivités locales
ils s'unissent ils sont ils travaillent
ensemble et depuis très très longtemps
malgré les divergences dans la
présidentielle
il n'y a pas à s'unir dans la
présidentielle puisqu'il y en a qu'un
qui était lui après c'est dans les
législatives c'est un autre débat et gym
assemblée là aussi d'entendre pierre
laurent à la fête de l'humanité ne pas
écarter la possibilité ici ou là de
trouver des accords avec le parti
socialiste qui a mis très en colère
d'ailleurs jean-luc mélenchon parlant
d'une stratégie dans 577
circonscriptions
donc ils ont des désaccords entre eux je
sais pas s'ils sont irréconciliables
mais en tout état de cause il y en a qui
veulent discuter avec nous dans les
législatifs d'autres qui refusent alors
parlons de votre primeur parce qu'on a
l'impression quand même que les contours
sont encore assez flou il ya des
interrogations chez certains candidats
arnaud montebourg dans le dans le même
sens est ce que le ps lui tout seul et
réconciliables est-ce que
aujourd'hui les frondeurs il ya de
multiples candidatures venant un noir de
montebourg marie noëlle lienemann gérard
filoche
est ce que est ce que ça va être
possible de faire partie alors de faire
participer françois hollande à la même
primaires c'est la décision que vous
avez prise mais ce que ça va être
possible de le faire sans y laisser trop
de plumes faut le ps je crois si on fait
si on suit notre débat et le précédent
attentes et a indiqué que nous avions
perdu énormément de plumes
donc je n'ai pas peur de la
confrontation je pense qu'elle peut être
salutaire pourquoi parce que en fin de
compte dans cette primaire nous aurons
toutes les positions de la gauche et
c'est une primaire de toute la gauche
par l'intermédiaire de des candidats
deux socialistes
d'un certain point de vue toutes les
positions de la gauche seront
représentés des écologistes des
socialistes critiquent ou des
socialistes défendent ans et pour cause
la politique gouvernementale
donc à partir de là nous aurons la
possibilité de trancher sur qui sera le
candidat est ce que nous ferons mais ce
que ça n'est pas humiliant pour le chef
de l'état que de la ligne est dans une
compétition
à côté de ces candidats dans la liste
vient d'être rappelé par des fous des
sciences ont quand même pourquoi ce
serait humiliant mais d'abord parce que
c'est le président sortant d'une part à
six pieds c'est un exercice sans leurs
arguments c'est un exercice démocratique
mais il ne s'agit pas de dieu ou de
dieuze descendants de l'olympe
il s'agit d'un président de la
république est un président de la
république qui a été attaqué par toulon
mais qu'il est candidat mais elle aimait
donc vous avez une contradiction
soit vous dites que le président de la
république à 15 % ou à 10% ne peut pas
se représenter soit à 15% et 10% il
n'est pas populaire dans l'ensemble de
l'opinion
et donc s'il se représente il va pas
m'être mis en cause parce qu'il va
débattre avec benoît hamon ou arnaud
montebourg il y aura un débat
il sera ou pas eu encore faut-il qu'il
soit candidat et puis à partir de là
tout le monde se rassemblera pour moi la
primaire c'est un moyen de rassembler
parce que s'il n'y a pas de primaires il
y aura des candidats
extérieur de la primaire et à ce moment
là je sais sur ce de ce qui va se passer
avec 4% ou 5% ne sera pas au deuxième
tour
parmi elles on s'en fiche elle aussi
comme un délit sinon tout va alors si on
comprend bien la question qui nous est
posée aujourd'hui c'est à par la droite
regardez tout ce qu'il nous faut il
comparer regarder la droite et la gauche
mais si je comprends bien à part dire au
secours la droite revient il n'y a rien
d'autre
mais c'est déjà essentiel parce que la
droite revient et en plus elle prévient
sur un programme que l'on n'a jamais vu
un programme mais d'abord honnêtement on
y viendra puisque vous interrogerez le
chaque candidat
ce programme il est il réalisable il est
tellement violent mais tellement violent
sur le plan économique je devrais bras
comment est ce qui se passerait ben je
vais dire d'abord on explose les
déficits serait formidable
ceux qui nous ont reproché de ne pas
juguler les déficits
aujourd'hui 10 bon allez on y va on s'en
fiche de toute façon on verra bien
comment ça arrangera et avec une relève
celle c'est un peu ce que vous dites
comment ils s'arrangent bruxelles oui
c'est ce qu'ils disent on s'arrangera
avec bruxelles ils s'arrangeront pas du
tout deuxièmement ils sont en train
d'emmener la france dans la situation
s'il était élu qui était celle que nous
avons connue c'est à dire que quand nous
sommes arrivés aux affaires
nicolas sarkozy nous a laissé une france
où on était entre bruxelles qui devait
pouvais faire prendre un certain nombre
de mesures sur l'état le fmi estimé que
la france pouvait être à nouveau sous
son égide et des mouvements sociaux qui
ne était prêt à surgir sur chaque
instant il a fallu petit à petit
redresser la france
oui mais là aussi vous avez fait le coup
de l'héritage vous aussi à des organes
qui vous feront peut-être pareil mais
ils nous feront exactement la chose sauf
que nous on leur laissera une situation
un peu plus l objectivement et d'orbey
écoutez moi je prendrais simplement ce
que disent qu'elles ont regagnés de 2017
2018 serait véritablement sais pas ce
que tu as droit mais aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui michel sapin et christian
eckert ont fait une conférence de presse
ils ont répondu point par point à ces
accusations
c'est un camouflage de la part de la
droite pour qu'on ne parle pas de leur
déficit mais il n'ya pas que les
déficits
ils vont revenir sur tout ce qu'on a
fait tout à part le mariage pour tous
parce qu'ils ont retrouvé que
un peu chaud encore qu'il ya des
candidats qu'ils y soient favorables
mais ils vont venir surtout ce qu'on sur
tout ce qu'on a fait le tiers payant le
le combat qu'on a mené pour redresser
l'école la création de poste trois cent
mille fonctionnaires en moins et c'est
vous croyez que ça va se faire
tranquillement comme cela donc ils vont
mettre là on revient c'est suffisant je
ne dis pas que c'est suffisance c'est
l'essentiel
oui elle revient et elle prévient voilà
c'est ce qu'il faut et français doivent
comprendre petit à petit vont le
comprendre
après il y aura un programme il y aura
des propositions pour le prochain
quinquennat on va pas bien se tourner
les pouces en disant ce qu'on a fait
c'était formidable
il arrive pour le défaire va travailler
là comment fera pas campagne sur le
bilan
mais on intégrera notre bilan vous je l'
ai dit tout à l'heure un de vos
collègues
on présentera notre bilan par rapport à
leur projet c'est très facile à faire je
le fais tous les week-ends en meeting ça
marche très très bien
à chaque fois on dit ce qu'on a fait et
on prend au choix sarkozy juppé
un des frères dalton là on la comprend
non non non non non non parce que les
quatre pour moi c'est les frères dalton
jacques dupâquier est jouable mais il
donc donc donc j'ai on prend comme ça
interactivement sur l'un et l'autre et
puis on voit bien que honnêtement les
gens sont convaincus sur le programme
économique est ce qu'il y en a pas un
qui trouve grâce à vos yeux qui soit
allez on va dire crédible raisonnable
mais ils sont pas raisonnables pour
qu'il passe qui sont dans une primaire
donc ils pensent que pour gagner l'après
mine et la primaire il faut aller plus à
droite que moi tu meurs aujourd'hui je
finisse peuvent définissent parce que
marine le pen est en tenue de camouflage
etc mais finissent par dépasser dans les
mots marine le pen sur l'ensemble des
sujets aujourd'hui elle parle pas de
racines chrétiennes dit oui à des
racines très tel mais qu'on était
laïcisé par l'universalisme évidemment
qu'elles se cachaient peut pas aller
devant les français avec le programme
qui est le sien ça n'aurait pas des
arguments que vous allez écouter vous
allez pouvoir répondre puisque
le parler ce matin du front national et
d'elle-même en se disant eh bien de
droite et de gauche
il est évident que vous retrouverez
madame dans le gouvernement qui sera le
mien des gens qui viendront du front
national mais peut-être aussi des gens
qui nous auront rejoint sur les grands
axes de défense de la patrie de la
nation parce que moi je crois qu'il y a
des je crois qu'il ya des patriotes de
droite et de gauche
voilà et quand nous disons nous sommes
ni de droite ni de gauche on pourrait
dire nous sommes et de droite et de
gauche
alors jean christophe cambadélis non
mais ni de droite ni de gauche ni et de
droite et de gauche extrême droite
je sais que ça va quand même pas ça mais
c'est extrême droite c'est à dire que le
ce qui fonde le front national ce
qu'elle ne peut pas gommer
c'est un souverainisme xénophobe il n'y
aurait rien de gauche au front national
derrière gauche un programme économique
mais moi je vais pas tomber dans la
comparaison du front national vous
croyez que c'est franchement sur les
telle mesure qui se sont présentés sur
le plan économique que les gens votent
pour le front national
ou c'est par rapport à ce qu'ils agitent
vis-à-vis de l'immigration et les
réfugiés et du reste enfin poser des
questions et faites comme moi du porte à
porte
vous verrez quand les portes du front
national sur ce que l'on vous dit ce que
l'on vous dit pas c'est ce qu'on vous
raconte pas c'est la csg ou
l'augmentation des impôts encore on vole
dix maires c'est plutôt sur le fait que
notre pays est envahi bas c'est ça le
fond de commerce du front national vous
parlez des réfugiés qu'est ce que vous
pensez de la levée de boucliers que l'on
constate aujourd'hui
parmi les candidats les républicains et
les élus locaux qui ont notamment au
ministre de l'intérieur parce que il
n'ya pas de concertation a priori sur
l'implantation de réfugiés de la jungle
de calais une question très importante
parce que nous avons monsieur wauquiez
qui a lancé une pétition contre le
démantèlement de la jungle
alors que monsieur que le président de
la région
la fée verte orange allier bertrand
voilà j'y arrive de la demande
et puis vous avez le front national qui
a créé une association sur le même sujet
donc on voit bien là que les deux
positions se chevauchent ou se
rapprochent moi ce jeu où vous dis c'est
que le gouvernement est sans peut pas
lui reprocher cherche à régler les
problèmes la jungle de calais il ya à
peine huit jours
tous les éditorialistes nous disait que
c'était une honte
il fallait régler ce problème on règle
ce problème et on nous dit on mais quand
même vous réglez ce problème en imposant
des gens dans un certain nombre
d'endroits bah oui à partir du moment où
un certain nombre de partis politiques
dont les républicains représentés à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat disent
qu'ils ne le feront pas défaut la levée
mais bien sûr mais bien sûr il faut
l'imposer
parce que cette répartition ça peut pas
être quand même que les socialistes ou
les hommes et les femmes de gauche qui
vont recevoir vous lancer dans cette
population que vous la poser comment
contient des réquisitions mais on peut
le faire sur des lieux sans lequel on
peut mettre en attendant soit qu'il soit
utiliser le droit d'asile soit qu'ils
soient renvoyés dans leur pays
franchement il ya aucun problème sinon
quand cette taxe c'est trop sinon c'est
trop simple on essaie de l'autoritarisme
ça sur les élus locaux méprenez pas de
l'autoritarisme c'est de la solidarité
nationale
après loket par une au journal du
dimanche de l'institut montaigne sur
l'islam il ya eu nombreuses positions et
notamment celle d'alain juppé qui a
déclaré ne pas accepter l'hystérie
déraisonnable autour de la question des
musulmans quand il parlait
d'accommodation à ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec lui mais monsieur juppé à
plusieurs langages bon quand il est
devant valeurs actuelles il dit le
regroupement la fin du regroupement
familial
je l'avais proposé avant nicolas sarkozy
mais quand il est confronté à une
déclaration de nicolas sarkozy
eh bien il fait une autre déclaration de
québec alain juppé je vais je vais
croire celui qui quand il était premier
ministre nous a fait les lois de vraies
ou celui qui dit vous ne seriez pas
aujourd'hui on va trop loin sur ces
questions je ne sais pas lequel des deux
au fond je pense que je lui ai dit tout
à l'heure
nicolas sarkozy et alain juppé sont
d'accord ils se démarquent simplement
pour avoir un électorat que l'un ne peut
pas conquérir et que l'autre ne ne peux
pas non plus conquérir les un aveu
conquérir les centristes l'autre veut
reconquérir l'électorat du front
national
tout ça c'est de l'électoralisme pour la
primaire qu'est ce que vous auriez
préféré
là où l'autre
chacun s'est dit que nicolas sarkozy ça
favoriserait françois hollande juppé se
serait terminée vous savez un alain
juppé est friable en campagne on le voit
s'énerve vite et personnel
oui on l'a vu récemment à strasbourg il
est très rapidement à nouveau droit dans
ses bottes il a une position qui n'est
ni centristes ni droitière il est un
tendre et là aussi il a aussi attaquable
que nicolas sarkozy lui est vraiment à
la droite de la droite je tiens à défaut
et la question de cette séquence c'était
ce qu'on s'oriente vers un nouveau
21-avril votre réponse c'est possible
c'est possible c'est possible que la
gauche ne soit pas au second tour c'est
pour cela qu'il faut tout faire pour la
rassemblé apaisé les tensions qui a pu
avoir au sein de la gauche
vous êtes d'accord pour dire avec le
chef de l'état dans l'interview au débat
que quel que soit le candidat qui sera
élu en 2017 il sera dans une situation
périlleuse parce que il sera élu avec
des électeurs qui se seront mobilisés
contre contre la présence du front
national donc une situation
en tout état de cause périlleuse pour le
prochain président de la république tout
à fait c'est la crise politique
française à partir du moment où vous
avez un front national qui tutoie les
30% pèse sur les débats
on le voit à droite et perturbe le
dispositif politique tel que nous le
nous l'avons connu jusqu'à présent
donc le problème qui résident toutes les
conséquences c'est que les candidats
aujourd'hui ne peuvent pas avoir 50%
il faut qu'il soit le plus haut dans
leur couloir c'est l'élément de
totalement nouveau du tri parquet le
plus haut dans le couloir pour françois
hollande sait combien c'est 30 % tant
que pour ceux arrivés au trône pour se
ré écouter on a fait 25 % lors des
élections régionales on a fait 24 % lors
des élections départementales dans une
campagne on peut aller chercher 5% le
socle de françois hollande pour vous
c'est rôle pour se hisser le sait ce que
représente la gauche de gouvernement
dans le paysage politique
est-ce qu'elle sera mobilisable ou est
ce qu'elle sera mobilisée
et la réponse à votre question sur le
deuxième tour se pose là et uniquement
là merci jean christophe cambadélis
d'avoir été avec nous aujourd'hui pour
cette deuxième édition de l'épreuve de
vérité on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine france soir